now who's this gentleman yeah he's now
his nostrils look like two [ __ ]
handcuffs
what's going on here
his gauges match his nostrils
uh he's got a debate club for it this
guy can breathe through everything
gangster don't get him and theo in the
same room
for you okay it comes to the side
that boy got a schnauzer on him for you
comes the see cheesy side dish you're
gonna go with the
liquid gold shells and cheese or
them uh craft macaroni
and cheese bad boys personally i'm gonna
go with them blue box headers
but uh let me know what you think gang
gang
this gangster
yeah i think his name's sean or
something shout out to sean get that off
chappelle's
[ __ ] fans only account
you can get that anywhere um man you you
bawling if you're doing the shells and
cheese
we didn't that was a special my birthday
when i was a kid maybe
it's thanksgiving you got to be a real
ball you have that
maybe your mom have a man over she'll
cook up the michelle's and cheese yeah
dog you knew you red panty night if that
shells and cheese came
out oh god i'd put my damn panties on
bro hell yeah
um what do you guys eat in the uh what
kind of macaroni and cheese do you have
over there in your community uh
cat and chapelle uh bro i don't [ __ ]
with macaroni and cheese
what oh my bad what
hey any psychopaths but hot dogs in it
some of my cousins did yeah that's
something i don't know
so we're not supposed to eat mac and
cheese but i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah you'll eat it yeah yeah yeah baby
that's what i'm talking about
all asians are lactose intolerant mostly
yeah mostly really
yeah yeah why do you think they don't
[ __ ] with milk oh yeah
dude when i was growing up if you want
to you sneak a milk dud into an asian
and watch them just unsettled
yeah yeah it's like putting a mento in a
[ __ ] coca-cola can
you can take down all of china with a
glass of milk
that's hilarious i'm getting king it or
sting it from this young lady
oh velveeta or crap yeah what did you
[ __ ] with
well we went uh but i think whatever the
more store-bought one was you know like
larry's uh
macaroni or whatever it was called no
what it was what it was
uh we couldn't afford the craft when i
was a kid so it would say
macaroni and cheese dinner on it and
it's black and white oh that was the one
that [ __ ] was watery as [ __ ]
yeah that's what i'm [ __ ] macaroni
and cheese it's just wack but dude
sometimes we would make the extra recipe
put a little bit of
butter in there you know put a little
bit of extra real cheese that's right
dog you know
hell yeah sometimes what my fat ass
would do is i'd open up another box and
put double the seasoning in it
oh really yeah make it real cheesy and
that's why i'm
a thicker gentleman now because my
parents would allow me to get away with
that
he said double the seasoning hell yeah
gianni was a fat kid
i was yeah i was a chubby kid yeah i had
a little chub on me but i leaned out
when i got older
[Laughter]
i leaned out when we got it when i got
older like we don't know that bro
oh wow i thought you're still fat no
dude you look good man
hello my instagram that white privilege
dude leaning out oh here's gianni right
here man
oh there you go look at that
we should do our own king of sting type
rough and rowdy we got gianni
boxes malik
malik yeah you could those
on social media man he's like six nine
kind of but he's like four or nine
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] no gianni's a champ man i'm just
telling you look that's the farm system
that we have here with podcasts